hello i would like to invite you to our
forthcoming worlds of speculative
fiction session
57 we are now in the seventh year of
this talk series in which we look at
great works and bodies of work of
speculative fiction so that's fantasy
sci-fi alternate history horror weird
all sorts of other things combined in
there and we are kicking off year seven
with a session on this novel by neil
stevenson anathem uh very interesting
work here some great world building a
lot of philosophical themes built into
it
the way that we
carry these out since we we started
revising it in coveting this originally
started as a face-to-face series but in
covid times we do a video premiere in
which i talk about some of the key
aspects of the book bring in some other
people from time to time and their
thoughts on it you know tap the the
author and their interviews and go into
you know some of the world building and
other cool aspects of it
we do that for about an hour and a half
sometimes a little bit longer the video
premieres and i'm there to do live chat
with anybody who's watching it following
that we do a video conferencing using
zoom for people who want to continue to
this the discussion or go more into
depth about the work and it's all told
about three hours so it's pretty
cool and intensive discussion of a very
interesting work of speculative fiction
this falls into the sci-fi
and more than fantasy i would say
so if you'd like to join us
going to be coming up this saturday
beginning at noon central and ending
around three o'clock the video premiere
and then video conferencing i hope that
some of you will join me for this
kickoff of year seven